[Aplausos]
[Música]
y 200 días fueron perdidos o invertidos
y cuando está esta pregunta la gente se
pregunta hoy de qué miércoles estás
hablando 1800 días de que y esto es
sencillo realmente hablando acerca de
los días de la universidad
y una pregunta válida la universidad
aprovechaste al cien por ciento o
realmente el tiempo que estuviste ahí la
perdiste y ahora lo que estoy hablando
ahora es acerca de un concepto que tal
vez rompe un poco esquemas rompe un poco
también paradigmas porque estoy hablando
acerca de algo en lo que estamos hoy
reunidos todos la universidad realmente
está bien ponerse en contra oa favor de
la universidad es una pregunta válida y
hace ya y vale la pena también acs pero
la respuesta realmente depende de dos
factores una de tu perspectiva y otra de
tu proyección de vida porque no depende
de que yo esté bien de que tú estés bien
sino de lo que tú estás deseando hacer
con tu vida y esa es la respuesta que
vamos a encontrar y de hecho hoy te reto
a que puedas encontrar tu proyección de
vida tu perspectiva y darte cuenta de tu
respuesta a tu manera pero antes quiero
que levante la mano derecha todos como
grupo de scouts o gere scouts cierto
levante la mano porque hoy vamos a hacer
un compromiso y este compromiso es
avanzamos hoy tomaré repitan conmigo hoy
tomaré una decisión para mi bienestar
otra vez hoy tomaré una decisión para mi
bienestar
pero quiero comenzar con insights
información para que sepan que no estoy
inventando de lo que estoy diciendo sino
que hay hechos atrás de todo lo que
estamos hablando en este momento y eso
es que más de 150.000 estudiantes cada
año salen del colegio y entra en la
universidad lo que muy pocos saben es
que apenas 95.000 realmente terminan la
universidad y terminan graduándose
contentos y puede finalmente colgar ese
título en la pared con cierto 5 años
1800 días invertidos o perdidos depende
la perspectiva y proyección de vida pero
lograste colgar ese título en la pared
ahora hay cierta información que vale la
pena resaltar y esta es que las personas
graduadas de 25 a 34 años uno de cada
cinco es desempleado y uno de cada diez
tomó el camino que tome yo de emprender
ahora hace falta estudiar si hace falta
tener experiencia también pero ninguna
de las dos va a ser determinante son
importantes que van a servir pero puedes
irte por el lado la experiencia generar
muchísima práctica o por la parte
académica y comenzar a auto educarte o
en una institución
hay un análisis que voy a hacer en este
momento que tal vez duela algunos como
en esta fotografía que le dolió de la
nalga a mi me dolería o durísimo es
cuando más lloró cuando tienen que
inyectar me yo siento que esto no es de
dios o sea porque meter un veneno en la
cola o en el brazo y eso duele y vamos a
hablar acerca de un tema que se llama la
bulimia académica y la bulimia académica
el estar llenando me de información en
un aula llenando de información que no
me nutre porque al final lo expulsó y no
voy a hacer el acto de expulsar pero el
expulsó en un examen pero realmente no
me quedan nutrientes no me queda
información y se genera un efecto mister
bean que cuando te preguntan oye en
macroeconomía tú aprendiste esto y
tristes miércoles como que no me acuerdo
lo cierto pero hay otro tema que es la
práctica y en la práctica como te
preguntan exactamente lo mismo y tú
sabes que ya lo viviste sabes que ya lo
hiciste tu respuesta es otra
ya tienes otra cara oye si sé cómo
hacerlo y pas a pas en la práctica pasa
también en la parte en la parte
académica ahora hay riesgos en ambas
partes
la academia tenemos un riesgo bastante
fuerte que es un limitante de tiempo se
restringe el tiempo estudias 15 horas al
día 18 horas al día y no tienes tiempo
para otras actividades también pasa que
tenemos profesores que no saben lo que
están enseñando nos siente que solamente
comenzó a educarse pero que no tiene
información real en la práctica de cómo
tienes que tú utilizar esa información y
llevarla al mundo real si pasa pasa
muchísimo también tenemos no regresamos
también tenemos una pérdida de dinero en
tutores porque al final estás
invirtiendo tanta plata en tu educación
al finalmente en diste de lo que estaban
hablando los profesores
vas a tutorías y es que pagar aparte más
las tutorías al final nunca se ven
reflejadas en tu práctica o en tu
conocimiento real sobre el tema y por
último la posibilidad de que nunca hayas
aprendido y tengas la cara de mister
bean
no sabes qué fue lo que pasó pasaron
1800 días y realmente no aprendiste nada
llegas a tu puesto de trabajo estás
emocionado
tu jefe te da la carpeta y te dice ahora
sí haz un plan de mercadeo para la
empresa y te caes frío
y por donde comienzo si ahora también
hay un riesgo en la parte práctica en tu
vida y si te dedicas a no estudiar en la
parte institucional sino aprobar en la
vida y aprender y esto es que vas a
equivocarte muchísimas veces aprendes y
te equivocas aprendes y te equivocas
aprendes y te equivocas y única forma de
poder aprender realmente equivocando te
pierdes muchísimo dinero experimentando
cosas que al final no están funcionando
y pasa el año pasado por ejemplo en mi
compañía perdió 30 mil dólares porque a
la final invertimos en un plan de
marketing un plan comercial que no
funcionó y pues para algunos tal vez
30.000 nos parece mucho pero para otros
30 mil es bastante plata y más cuando
tienes 20 años y se oye podríamos haber
ganado un dinero pero no lo hicimos
porque porque nos jalamos yo lo besa con
maestría pagué mi semestre en harvard
estamos de acuerdo nos costó 30.000
dólares poder aprender y créanme que ese
mismo error nunca más en la vida
porque me dolió más que una inyección en
la nalga totalmente influencias que
intentan enseñarte pero no saben y saben
incluso menos que tú el típico bonito
que te comienza a dar consejos de que
oye debería hacerlo de esta forma tú qué
nota suya es te ven te voy a dar un
consejo de que no tiene que hacer
realmente no sabe lo que es enseñándote
y hay gente que sí puede enseñarte que
sabe muchísimo gente con mucha
experiencia que puede darte unos hawks
realmente práctico y por último tenemos
que la única opción es demostrarle al
mundo que tomaste la decisión correcta
es un riesgo gigantesco porque si te
sales de la universidad tu familia te va
a ver feo tu abuelita te va a quitar el
apellido
y van a decir te has que no te fue bien
es porque no terminaste la universidad
es porque nunca sacaste un título es más
te vale y de verdad te digo más te vale
que si toma la decisión de salir de la
universidad por dios santo no te
equivoques tomarlo porque entendiste tu
perspectiva de vida y tu proyección de
iu está sumamente claro ahora también
existen muchísimas oportunidades en la
parte la parte académica tenemos un
networking impresionante bastante
importante también tenemos el título
universitario no cierto para poder
colgar en la pared si es que eso te da
confianza porque lo tienes ahí y también
tenemos una mayor seguridad en la parte
de empleos vas a poder conseguir un
empleo más fácil hay muchas compañías
que ya no están buscando gente con
título sino gente con mucha experiencia
pero todavía tenemos en nuestro país
empresas que buscan personas graduadas
ya no hay siquiera del universidad sino
gente con master a2 incluso con
doctorados y en ciertos cargos
ahora la vida también hay tres puntos
super super importantes y es que tú
eliges a los mentores en la parte
práctica tú eliges quien me enseñarte en
mi caso tengo gerentes de muchísimas
multinacionales que son mis mentores
personales gente que se sienta conmigo
me dona horas literal porque no les pagó
nada les invito un café y comienzan a
retroalimentar me en que estoy
equivocando me qué es lo que debería
corregir y por qué lo hacen porque ven
que tengo esa hambre pero quiero comerme
al mundo pero no se dice que la
universidad no va a enseñar me quiere
ser inventor voy a aprender contigo no
quiero equivocarme y la gente lo hace
accedes a un networking impresionante
mis amigos por ejemplo son amigos de 40
años yo tengo 20 pero mis amigos son de
40 porque a la final elegí es a esa
gente para que se rodee conmigo que
puede enseñarme que me nutra porque
siento que aprendo más de gente un poco
más adulta que tal vez sentarme con un
chico de mi edad y juzgar a nadie pero
que tal vez no podamos tener una
conversación un poco más madura que
pueda trascender a otro nivel
y por supuesto tienes más experiencia
que otros es como que una bendición y
una maldición al tiempo porque tienes un
cerebro de una persona de 35 años en un
cuerpo de 20
la gente dice oye tú tienes 40 tú tienes
tantos no yo tengo 20 y los incumplidos
no soy tan adulto como piensas
ahora en perspectiva quiero que tengas
una pregunta y esta pregunta es eres una
persona segura o eres una persona
arriesgada te atreves a tomar retos en
la vida te atreves a dar ese paso salir
de la universidad y decir oye voy a
enfrentar el mundo ya dar todo lo que
pueda pero realmente voy a tomar el
riesgo o no es una persona más mesurada
mucho más calmada que está muy bien y
prefieres irte por lo seguro sin tener
tu título universitario estar tranquilo
que vas a conseguir un empleo aún
sabiendo que 1 de cada 5 no van a
conseguirlo
ahora tenemos otra otra parte que es la
predicción de vida y en la que vamos a
proyectarnos y decir ok que quiero
alcanzar con mi vida y aquí vale vale la
pena que tengas esta pregunta y esta
pregunta es
avanzamos que quieres alcanzar en tu
vida muy pocos jóvenes y siempre doy
charlas anualmente más de 20 mil jóvenes
en nuestro país y se pregunta a los
jóvenes hoy y que quieren mi vida no sé
no sé que quiero alcanzar no sé en qué
quiero convertirme no sé si es que
quiero ser abogado no sé si quiero ser
doctor no sé si quiero ser un superhéroe
o si quiero ser una persona que se
dedica a cocinar no sé qué quiero y la
proyección de vida escúchame esto es lo
más importante que debes tener si no
sabes a dónde estás yendo mejor quédate
quieto sigue analizando entiende a ti
mismo y comienza a caminar cuando ya
sepas y la pregunta que luego nace es
entonces la experiencia vale más que el
conocimiento debería considerar o tal
vez debería considerar como que más o
más oportuno más más valioso el
conocimiento que la experiencia la
respuesta es que ambos son importantes
lo que te digo es nunca dejes de
aprender solamente que encuentres
realmente qué forma de aprendizaje está
correcta para ti para mí en definitiva
no era la universidad pero si sigo con
muchos mentores yo estudio de la gente
que quiere estudiar
abro libro y comienzo todo carme porque
siento que conocimiento es básico pero
también la experiencia y equivocándote
perdiendo plata llorando en tu casa un
día porque dices bestia que verón la
empresa y ahora cinco familias se
quedaron sin trabajo eso duele más que
sacar cero en una calificación y te lo
puedo firmar más te apuesto pues en mi
lugar y digan oye quedó mi empresa y
tres personas se quedaron sin trabajo
eso viene más que cualquier otra cosa
más que no haber estudiado más que haber
sacado un cero eso realmente te marca y
dices lo que cada paso que doy debe ser
con mucha más mesura así que sencillo tú
te arriesgarías o no te arriesgarías
prefieres y por lo seguro o prefieres
dar pasos poco a poco pero seguir
avanzando y que ser un poco más y
consejo siempre va a ser que sigas
siempre aprendiendo nunca dejes de
aprender no vale la pena no aprender si
estudia dos horas tres horas cuatro
horas al día a lo que quieras pero sigue
auto educando te sigue generando
conocimiento y sigue convirtiendo la
persona que quiere ser aprendiendo
también experimenta
porque puedes experimentar es básico que
puedas palmar vas a tocarlo sentirlo y
decir oye estaba acá no no me equivoqué
horrible y comienzas a testear y
comienzas a testear y sepas por qué
línea vas a tomar también vive no te
estreses eres joven tienes 20 años 25
años de edad que tengas no te estreses
vive tranquilo aprende experimenta vive
pero sobre todo y lo más importante
disfruta el proceso porque el proceso
nunca va a terminar nunca vas a dejar de
aprender nunca vas a dejar de seguir
experimentando y lo más lindo de la vida
es eso que podemos seguir caminando y
que nunca sabemos todo que nunca lo
hemos probado todo sino que cada día
cada paso que damos aporta nuestro
crecimiento
a la final eres tú el que tiene el timón
y tú diriges tu barco a donde quieras
llevarlo mi nombre es ariel gonzález
tengo 20 años de edad y el sido
emprendedor toda mi vida y para los que
se preguntaban si es quien es bote de la
voz es que si estudiar pues si
definitivamente tuve que votar en la
universidad no estudie hasta tercer
semestre y dije no esto esto creo que no
es para mí
y definitivamente no lo hice y de hecho
comencé a emprender desde muy temprana
edad a mis 8 años donde mi primera
compañía justo con con mi hermana
y de mí me di cuenta que mi vocación era
el de ser emprendedor intentar intentar
intentar perseverar nunca desistir hasta
que algo funcione en ese transcurso me
di cuenta que también el colegio me
quitaba mucho tiempo así que los que se
preguntaban si es que me bote del
colegio
la respuesta es no por favor esa mente
retorcida si termine el colegio termine
el colegio en el colegio pero de una
forma muy diferente estudia cuarto
quinto y sexto curso a distancia en
estados unidos estudiaba cuatro horas al
día
resaltaron tercer curso de grado a los
16 años ya estaría horita grado a la
universidad pueden creer pero no me
dediqué a emprender comencé a quedar
compañías comencé a probar comienza
hacer muchísimas actividades muchísimas
cosas y me di cuenta que mi vocación y
va por esa línea siempre probar intentar
experimentar porque era joven soy joven
y lo mejor que puedo hacer ahora es
cristiano cristiano vivir y disfrutar el
proceso ahora cuando hablo de home
school no es cierto la gente piensa oh
qué industria das a distancias privadas
como que como que en internet no es
cierto lo respondo sitios privada por
internet o sea que tu familia era así
eran todos los nerds mamá te enseñado a
tu papá también cómo funciona eso la
respuesta es no para nada
tampoco me veía como ese niño tampoco no
realmente no era mi caso indicado ha
sido todo lo contrario ha sido siempre
extrovertido soy una persona muy
emprendedora y me encanta eso y eso se
lo debo realmente a mi manera en la que
me eduqué y es por eso que estoy aquí
con ustedes porque informe educación ha
sido muy diferente no seguir el sistema
tradicional de estudio me salieron del
colegio a temprana edad para estudiar a
distancia estoy a distancia en eeuu con
la universidad realmente no empató
conmigo salí he tomado cursos
gerenciales donde está realmente el
presidente de una mega compañía estoy al
lado que paguen lo mismo que el pago
1500 dólares por el curso sentado
escuchando y me dicen mi hijo pásame
uita
y me gusta porque digo que estoy
aprovechando mi edad para hacer algo
para lo productivo y si dime mi hijo no
hay problema mi hijo está súper bien
ahora lo que aprendí en mis 20 años de
edad son dos cosas una a estudiar por mi
cuenta aprendí que los mejores mentores
van a estar siempre en una biblioteca
si yo el hijo de quien estudió con un
libro y digo donald trump hoy vas a
hacer tú mi mentor warren buffett tuvo
hoy vas a enseñarme algo productivo tuvo
robert kiyosaki va a enseñarme acerca
del liderazgo y tú vas a enseñarme
hablar en público del carnegie y
comienza a estudiar comienza a aprender
comienzo a probar porque así es la vida
testear no estar en un laboratorio
metiéndote información sino probar las
cosas aprender y el segundo punto
aprender a resolver problemas
actualmente tengo siete intentos de
compañías 4 no funcionaron intentaba
había un tiempo que me dedicaba a crear
empresas que dije dos años vamos a crear
empresas programa una no funcionaba
probada otra tampoco funcionaba probada
otra tampoco funcionaba hasta aquí
entendí que estaba haciendo algo mal
ligeros y que está pasando comencé a
estudiar más comencé a aprender más
actualmente tengo ya siete intentos tres
compañías funcionan estadios y están en
eeuu
otra está en colombia otra está en
ecuador
y me encanta porque este es un ejemplo
de que ser joven es ser emprendedores es
posible no hace falta tener 50 años de
edad para alcanzar algo en la vida tengo
20 yo no siento que logrado nada para
nada pero siento que tal vez di un paso
más y me faltan 999 todavía pero siento
que estoy avanzando no estoy sentado
solamente llenándome información parece
cinco años no saberlo sino que ha
avanzado poco a poco para poder hacer
algo así que es que rescato algo yo de
mis 20 años es que vale la pena
mencionar que no perdí nada
solamente he aprendido y lo que he hecho
es aprender a vivir muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]